[Musica]
buongiorno buonasera a tutti il mio nome
bianca filicori sono autrice
ricercatrice per domus e per il décor e
sono qui perché un anno fa ho fondato un
gruppo facebook che poi è diventata una
piattaforma digitale che si chiama
forgotten architektur un progetto che ha
proprio quello come obiettivo quello di
indagare e scovare le architetture
moderne dimenticate in europa e nel
resto del mondo
sono stata invitata quindi a riflettere
sul tema della pausa e sulle sue varie
declinazioni e ho deciso proprio di
parlare di questo argomento partendo
dall idea di cosa significa amministrare
un gruppo facebook di questo tipo
significa pensare a un nuovo medium di
comunicazione per parlare della
disciplina architettonica in una maniera
sicuramente informale perché l'idea di
base di questo gruppo è quella propria
di trasformare le persone in utenti che
condividono progetti che loro ritengono
dimenticato all'interno della
piattaforma è un progetto che occupa
il tempo libero di una persona quindi
momenti di pausa un momento di oz è un
momento ludico è sicuramente la cosa che
più affascina il pubblico è proprio il
modo in cui una disciplina storicamente
considerata come una disciplina che fa
parte di una sovrastruttura assuma ora
toni informali che sono quelli di
facebook anche nel dialogo che si
instaura tra me e gli utenti o le
discussioni che si creano tra gli utenti
per questo il tema della pausa è proprio
legato in questo caso all'idea di un
dialogo informale riguardo una
disciplina che sicuramente non ha questa
tendenza a prendersi diciamo poco sul
serio anche se non non credo sia poco
serio parlare di architettura in una
maniera così informale tant'è che quello
che voglio fare oggi a citare una delle
figure più influenti del mondo
dell'architettura italiana è uno dei
primi a utilizzare un linguaggio
informale all'interno dei suoi testi che
ettore sottsass junior ettore sottsass
junior figlio di ettore sottsass senior
che maggio principalmente noto per le
sue suo design per la sua collaborazione
con olivetti anche scritto dei testi
meravigliosi che invito tutti a leggere
di cui oggi ci tengo a leggervi a legger
bene uno che è stato pubblicato nel
maggio 1965 su domus in occasione della
mostra la casa abitata a palazzo strozzi
di firenze una mostra dove 15 architetti
italiani erano stati chiamati a
realizzare arredamenti spazi
dell'abitare che rappresentino proprio
questa idea di abitare italiano
e mentre tutti i colleghi di sottsass
disegnano lo studio il soggiorno
si dedicano in sostanza gli spazi del
professionista o gli spazi del della
famiglia sottsass decide di chiamare di
disegnare la camera da letto che lui
chiama la camera dell'amore oltre ad
utilizzare un linguaggio informale
sottsass parla anche di amore
all'interno dell'architettura quindi
parla di sentimenti all'interno di una
rivista come la rivista domus in una
maniera del tutto innovativa rispetto a
quelli che erano i temi del tempo e
scrive così il kamasutra el antico libri
indiano di come fare l'amore e lignani
sapevano come fare l'amore dice nel
capitolo terzo deve vivere il cittadino
in una città in un grosso villaggio in
una zona onesta o in una località
affollata la casa deve essere situata
vicino a un ruscello è divisa in
parecchie zone per usi diversi
la dimora deve essere circondata da un
giardino e contenere due appartamenti
uno esterno e un interno l'appartamento
interno va riservato alle donne della
casa quello esterno deve essere
profumato a profusione e contenere un
enorme letto morbido coperto da un
lenzuolo bianco immacolato leggermente
sollevato nel centro è circondato da
ghirlande e da vasi di fiori il letto
deve avere un baldacchino ed essere
dotato di due cuscini uno per la testa e
uno per i piedi la stanza deve contenere
anche un sofà ea di sopra deve esserci
un piccolo scaffale dove posare unguenti
profumati per la notte fiori brocchi di
collirio e altri profumi usati per
rinfrescare l'alito come pure alcune
bucce di limone sul pavimento vicino al
suo fa deve esserci sempre una
sputacchiera di ottone un cofanetto prix
gioielli un liuto appeso a un dente di
elefante una tavola da disegni profumi
qualche libro e ghirlande di amaranto
giallo la stanza deve contenere anche un
sedile rotondo una scatola di giochi e
una tavola per i dati nell'appartamento
esterno deve esserci sempre una gabbia
per uccelli e la stampa e la stanzetta
separata va riservata alla scultura alla
modellatura delle
ed altri divertimenti nel giardino deve
esserci un altalena a ruota oltre che un
altalena ordinaria è anche un padiglione
estivo con alcune panchine per poter
sedere e poi continua mi piacciono le
storie d'amore
le poesie d'amore mi piacciono le
filosofie che parlano d'amore mi
piacciono le religioni che parlano
d'amore quello vero quello che si fa tra
ragazzi e ragazze mi pare che
bisognerebbe ritrovare un posto speciale
nella vita di oggi per fare l'amore per
l'amore voglio dire che l'amore l'idea
di fare l'amore il tema dovrebbe essere
il centro della vita e la vita dovrebbe
essere costruita intorno all'amore e i
simboli che nella società contemporanea
sono organizzati intorno al potere alla
potenza alla presunzione alla rapacità
al denaro e alla violenza
dovrebbero essere organizzati secondo me
intorno all'amore vero se la gente
pensasse di più all'amore senza le
oscenità e le porcherie
se la gente ci pensa se di più sul serio
con felicità
certo non avrebbe il tempo di fare tutte
quelle stupidate che si fanno in vietnam
per esempio o nel congo per esempio o
dovunque quelle macabre stupidate che si
sono sempre fatte si faranno nelle
prigioni d'america in quelle della
russia e in ogni prigione o guerra o
massacro in ogni posto dove si usa
violenza
perciò mi è venuto in mente di fare una
stanza da letto e questo pensiero per me
è molto meno peregrino di quanto possa
sembrare
è una proposta molto più serie e sociale
come si direbbe oggi di quanto non possa
sembrare diretta come a cercare di
salvarsi con l'amore o la pigrizia con
l'occhio il silenzio e la meditazione
più che con la storia distruttive
velenosa del benessere
naturalmente tutti mi prenderanno in
giro e tutti mi diranno che è molto più
importante di segnare un bagno una
cucina che non una stanza da letto e
tutti mi diranno che è molto più
importante decidere dove mettere la
lavatrice o la televisione è ancora più
importante decidere quanti metri quadri
anzi centimetri quadri ci vogliono
perché ci sia anche la macchina
lavapiatti che in italia non è non è
ancora arrivata ma prima o poi ci sarà
qualcuno dirà prendendomi in giro che è
molto più importante avere un bel conto
in banca
la jaguar sotto la porta e un bel
di granito al cimitero mi diranno queste
cose che sento dire ogni giorno e quando
mi dicono queste cose io so già che sta
per cominciare un'altra guerra
ettore sottsass junior una camera da
letto pubblicata in domus numero 426 nel
maggio 1965 la pagina 51 a pagina 54
io vi ringrazio per l'ascolto e adesso
seguiranno un paio di minuti di video in
cui viene raccontato forgotten
architektur un video realizzato da
margherita murray
[Musica]
lì